17 of itcs 2022
roughly the topic of this session is
algorithmic graph theory and you can see
all the full talks on youtube
in this session what we're going to do
is as is tradition for itcs i'll give a
couple minutes of introduction to the
papers and then each of the five papers
will have about 10 minutes to present
so the five papers in this session are
the following so we have a unifying
framework for characterizing and
computing with measures
fixed parameter sensitivity oracles
fpt algorithms for finding near cliques
and c closed graphs
vertex fault tolerant
and correlation detection in trees for
planted graph alignment
so all of these papers
all of these papers have
some unifying theme to them
and that unifying theme is
uh unification
so
that is to say all of these papers take
several different ideas and unify them
and i would argue that this is a
important thing to be doing
especially today in theoretical computer
science as the field has gotten larger
and has
had more and more sub areas and a wider
reach it becomes increasingly important
to take different concepts and
develop theories that unify them
so
i'll describe briefly how each of these
five papers fits into this theme
okay so the first paper um is called a
unifying framework for characterizing
and computing with measures it actually
has the word unifying in its title
and what this paper does
is
it
uh okay the slides seem to be they're
like okay there we go
um what this paper does is that they
study a graph measure that captures
several different already well studied
graph measures such as tree width click
width and mim width
the next paper is called fixed parameter
sensitivity oracles and what this paper
does is they combine the ideas
of
sensitivity oracles with fixed parameter
tractability
so traditionally sensitivity oracles
have been studied mostly for distances
whereas this paper says let's apply the
idea of sensitivity oracles to some
classic fixed parameter tractable
problems such as a k-path and k-vertex
cover
the next paper fbt algorithms for
finding near-cliques in c-closed graphs
this paper actually presents a
unification of theory and practice in
the sense that they develop an algorithm
that and prove theoretical guarantees on
it
and this algorithm actually behaves
similarly to algorithms that have
already been used in practice in the
past
and in particular these algorithms are
for finding communities in social
networks
the next paper is vertex fault tolerant
emulators
and this paper combines the ideas of
fault tolerance and emulators
and emulators are a graph structure that
are similar to another graph structure
called spanners and the punchline of
this paper is that
in the standard setting where you don't
have fault tolerance it turns out that
spanners and emulators have similar
bounds or the same bounds whereas if you
go into the fault tolerance setting
emulators actually perform better than
spanners
the final paper in this session is
correlation detection in trees for
planted graph alignment
and for this paper what they do is they
define a new statistical problem called
correlation detection in trees
and then they take this new problem and
draw connections from it to a previously
studied problem called partial recovery
for graph alignment
this is the end of the overview so with
that i will stop sharing and welcome the
first speaker
you can go ahead and share your screens
um so the first speaker one moment i
have to
uh the first speaker will be lars yafke
and
um the presentation is about a unifying
framework for characterizing and
computing with measures
yeah
thank you for the very nice introduction
so what i'm going to talk about in this
talk is with measures of graphs
and before i start and get into the
details i just want to give you a
general picture of what this usually
looks like
so we have some graph g
and we want to decompose it in some
algorithmically useful way so
one way of doing that for example as
it's done in tree width is that we take
subsets of the vertices of the graph and
we arrange them in a tree-like structure
right and then you get a picture sort of
like this and then you put some
technical conditions on top that will uh
make this decomposition useful in
algorithms okay
all right and then the width of this
decomposition
is a numerical value that tells you
something about the complexity of the
decomposition
right so as i said
in this example one way of measuring the
width would be
to just look at the largest vertex
subset that you have in this tree
structure okay and this is actually
more or less how the tree width of a
graph is is defined
then the width of a graph is just a
minimum width over all its
decompositions
okay and
why these things why are these things
useful in algorithms well very often you
can just move along the tree and do some
kind of dynamic programming procedure
and very often this gives you algorithms
that are polynomial time if the width is
constant
okay so there are of course
several width measures that have been
defined and the way you define these
which measures can be
very different from
one to the next
so
we have these two examples for so on the
left we have something that roughly
corresponds to tree width and here on
the right i show how we define the
clique with very roughly so in clique
with
what you do is you have again a certain
tree structure but this time the tree
represents
like a series of operations of how to
construct your graph
and in particular you do this with label
graphs for example here you take a
disjoint union of two graphs and
then there are some other operators that
for example tell you to connect every
vertex labeled 1 with every vertex label
2
and so on and so forth
and now the width in this case
is
is the number of labels that appear
in this industry or in this
construction sequence
and
it doesn't matter if you understand the
details of this now or not the point is
that you can see that these things are
very very different from each other yeah
but at the same time we call both of
these things width
all right
now
there are like i said there are many
width measures that have been defined
and
so these are some of them
and
one thing that you can do is you can
look at these with measures and ask
yourself okay how powerful are they
in the sense that
you want to look at
the families of graphs that they
are bounded on
and then you can derive a hierarchy like
this so in this picture
um the width measures that are higher up
are strictly more powerful than the ones
than the ones that are below
right and if two width measures are in
the same box then they are bounded on
the same
kind of graphs
all right so
okay so what we did in this work is
we had a look at
this sort of picture
we take a step back and we want to know
is there something that these with
measures have in common right
can we search for some unifying theories
why we call some graph invariance with
and others
we don't um
all right and if you want to do such a
thing there are two things that you have
to do one is you have to unify the way
you decompose the graph
and the other one is the that you have
to unify the way in which in which you
measure the width of this decomposition
okay
so
all right so the way we did this is the
following so the type of decomposition
that we look at
basically corresponds to a recursive
decomposition of the vertex set of the
graph
so you can think of this as kind of a
divide and conquer scheme
that you want to
run on your graph so you take your graph
g
you split it into two smaller parts
and again you split these into two
smaller parts and so
on and um
okay and then so what would be the width
of such a decomposition so i think
like you decompose your graph into these
small pieces and then you want to solve
your favorite problem once you arrive at
the small grass of course it's trivial
to solve the problem but then you have
to go back up and you have to combine
solutions for the smaller graphs
in order to
obtain solutions for the bigger graph
and at this stage
and at this stage it's of course
important
what does the
what is the structure of the cuts that
appear along this decomposition
right so if you have a very simply
structured cut
then combining two solutions uh yeah
combining a solution from one side and
from the other is probably quite simple
while if you have a very complicated
structure here in this cut then
it might be a bit more difficult
and this is why
we say okay the width of such a
decomposition is basically the
complexity
of the cuts that appear in this process
but again there are many ways of of
measuring the complexity
of these cuts and
in fact there are many width measures
that have been defined using this type
of decomposition
so one example is you just take the
maximum matching size that appears
across the cut
and another example
would be to take the gf2 rank over the
binary adjacency matrix of this
bipartite graph
so again you see
that there are many different ways of
measuring the complexity
and what we want again is to unify the
way
that we measure the complexity here
and the way we do it is as follows
so
we basically consider a family of
bipartite graphs f
and then the corresponding f branch with
counts in every cut
what is the largest size of any graph
that appears as an induced subgraph
across the cut that is contained in your
family f
okay
so now you can
yeah now you have this this width
parameter and for every new uh graph
family f
you get some new width measure but you
can see that they're all defined in the
same way
all right so i'm cheating here a little
bit we are not really caring about the
size of the graph but rather the
intersection of the vertex set of a
graph with one side of the cut
all right
therefore we also require some symmetry
constraints so we don't really want to
have a different complexity if we look
at the cut from left to right or from
right to left
therefore we only allow bipartite graphs
that have equally sized sides
okay
uh second of all it's sort of unnatural
to skip with values right if you have a
measure that says you have some graph of
with three sum of with five but none of
with four
that doesn't really make sense
and um
therefore we require um
this family has to require a property we
called par hereditary
which is the following so you look at
these bipartite graphs and you partner
up every vertex on the left with one
vertex on the right
and then you require that if you look at
any subset of the partners then this
again induces a graph in your family
f
so for example here family f1 is does
not have this property
because if we take um
for example the
yeah everybody except the first
pair of partners then we have an
edgeless graph
and this is not a graph that is in this
family f1
on the other hand f2 does have this
property because
every subset of the partners just gives
you a smaller matching and this is the
family of all matchings and therefore it
has this property
you have to hurry up a little bit
so what does this capture
so in fact for all of these with
measures that are marked green
um
we can find some family f
that gives us something that is at least
asymptotically equivalent to this uh to
this width measure
all right but this may not be so
surprising because you can just have
there are many choices that you can make
you can have uh
yeah so so it's not surprising that
there's some family of graphs that
actually matches one of these with
measures
but in fact we show that you can
restrict yourself further so we say that
a family is
identifiable for all and there's
precisely one graph of order two n in
your family
and then we showed it if you have some
family f and you basically throw out
all your graphs
except
the ones that are from a size
identifiable family then what you get is
still equivalent to your original width
measure
and the nice thing is that there are
only six
bipartite graph families that have these
properties and they look like this
so it's the edgeless graphs matchings
chain graphs and the bipartite
complements
to summarize there are many width
measures out there we want to find a
unifying framework that
characterizes
many of them at once
and we
okay so there are two things we had to
do we unified the decomposition method
here we chose this method of branch
decomposition
then we unified the way we compute the
cut function
and we saw that this already captures
many of these width measures
and interestingly there are only six
graph families that we have to use
for for this family f to give
different width measures
all right and we also showed that if
your graph has low tree with plus max
degree tree depth or
feedback edge set number then we can
approximate any of these with measures
efficiently
um okay that's it thanks for your
attention
okay are there any questions for lars
uh in the meantime the next speaker
martin you can start sitting up
currently the sharing is tech
okay i'll move right along but if anyone
has any lingering questions we can also
have time for all of to ask questions to
all of the panelists at the very end
okay great so our next speaker is martin
shernick and the topic of the
presentation is fixed parameter
sensitivity oracles
uh yeah as nicole already stated very
nicely in the beginning of the session
it's essentially about
proposing a new research direction by
combining ideas
from two areas that were previously
disjoint
the first one is that of sensitivity
oracles
where the idea is to maintain the graph
property under edge pairs
so in this example we have certain pairs
of vertices and the shortest paths in
between them it might be that if some
edge fails in that graph that the
distance increases and we want to
prepare for that
the specific thing about sensitivity is
that these failures come in batches
but we know their maximum number at once
this is the sensitivity f we know that
we only have to prepare for f failures
at most
this is also the main difference to
dynamic graphs where these edge
modifications come one by one but are
potentially unbounded in number
and to get an oracle we want to
pre-process that graph once into a small
structure that we can then query when
needed so specify some failing edges and
get the graph property back
and this is mostly researched for
polynomial time computable properties
for example au pairs shortest path the
conductivity of that graph
but
some very interesting graph properties
are not polynomial time computable as we
know
but
um
some of them are at least fixed
parameter tractable which is the other
area that means the input graphs come
augmented with some integer parameter we
have seen the last torque for example it
could be the width
in my examples that will be the solution
size
but the common thing is that we restrict
our attention to graphs with parameter k
then this can be computed in time do you
see my mouse
anyway then um
this can be computed in some function of
k times some fixed polynomial
so the textbook example is that we only
care about a vertex cover of size k
we can compute one if one exists in time
two to the k times k times n
and it does not matter whether we fix k
to two this is then a linear time
algorithm or for 42 this is still a
linear time algorithm
and we observed that
many fbt algorithms have in some sense
innate fault tolerance
so if you think of the standard
branching algorithm for vertex cover
um
[Music]
you in the same time go and you can not
only compute one solution but all of
them for decision problems this is not
necessary but this sort of redundancy
can be made into fault tolerance and to
make this explicit we propose some fixed
parameter sensitivity oracles
which are oracles with the sensitivity f
for some fpg property
and to make clear what we really want is
we fix the same parameter k for all
queries so the only thing that changes
over queries is the set of failing edges
and what we strive for is some
pre-processing time of some function of
f and k
times some fixed polynomial so if you
survive something f p t and the
parameter f plus k
so this sensitivity fits nicely in this
parameterized setting also in this sense
that you can just define it as another
parameter in that sense
what we do not want is just something
in k because we can achieve this by
essentially cycling through all failure
set and computing from scratch so this
does not give us anything
and as query time we want something that
is significantly faster
than computing from scratch which of
course depends then what is known about
the fpt property in question
there are some works for fpt on dynamic
graphs
but
none of these works take into account
this fixed sensitivity f so the maximum
number of failures we have to prepare
for
and we think this is an omission that a
gap that needs to be closed because
it
really lends itself essentially as
another parameter and what is uh also
interesting for itcs there was some work
two years ago
where they started with the classical
fault tolerant problem something about
fault tolerant spanners we hear later
on some special graph class and then
they took the insights they gained there
back to the classical fbt world so
essentially the other way around
two years back
and as an example problem for this
highlight talk i have vertex cover
so this is
the current fastest algorithm to compute
the k vertex cover in this time so this
is the bar we have to beat for the query
time if you're super
and the first thing we showed is that
some form of carnalization specifically
for this vertex cover problem also holds
in the fault tolerance sense and that
you can compute an equivalent graph size
only depends on k and f
in polynomial time
which is already pretty nice because
then your query time for all what you do
later on and also the space of your data
structure only depend on f and k no
longer in the input graph size
but still
what we inherit from sensitivity oracles
is that you have to make careful
trade-offs between the space you allow
and the pre-processing time and query
time which now all depend on f and k
and how these parameters relate to each
other this is a pretty
common observation for data structures
that there's not one single data
structure that is best for all
parameters
so here i confine myself to
some f that is smaller than k and still
we have we'll have our hands full
balancing space pre-processing time and
query time
and our first solution
i already hinted that for vertex cover
we just take the standard branching and
edge
at this this edge fails option
and we get from this something in space
3 to the f k
which is essentially computable time
proportional to its space
but has a query time that depends only
on f
so this is something you want to do if
you only want to prepare or need to
prepare for one or two failures
but
want to know the information about large
vertex covers so if your k is super
large but your f is moderate you
might want to go in this direction
but still you might take issue with an
exponential dependency on f
so we try to bring that down
to something polynomial here i use the
assumption that f is smaller than k so
there's something hidden in s as well
but
usually you pay for
improvements on one side
at the other
in this case we get this k square in the
exponent
which for a large k might be much larger
than already this 3 to the f plus k so
usually if you try to bring one of these
down
[Music]
something else increases
and
if you want to bring for example this
exponential space down to something
polynomial in the parameters
we can just reuse what elm and michigan
vs alaska williams did for dynamic
graphs and get something
in space k square so even independent of
the input size or something you really
want to do for example on small edge
devices
but
what you pay for this is a super huge
query times almost
what you would pay for computing a
vertex cover from scratch
you get rid of the input size but still
it's a pretty uh huge query time and
this is a common theme that you have to
balance these kind of things
to get to the open problems uh nice
thing about new research direction is
that essentially everything is open
the most pressing things is to advance
the fixed parameter sensitivity organs
to more problems
so we have vertex cover and k-path as
nicole mentioned but uh would be great
to have more of them
and
we have to reduce the dependency on f
and k they are not optimized yet
we cannot hope for fully polynomial uh
for fpg
but um
i think there is room for improvement
for example
two to the k square
and something i didn't have time to
mention in the highlights we also found
some applications of parameterization in
the classical fault tolerant world
in the sense that sometimes if you relax
the objective in some parameterized
sense you can sidestep known lower
bounds
which is uh i think pretty cool
and with this thanks a lot
are there any questions for martin
okay shweta you can start setting up
again we'll have more time for questions
for all of the panelists at the end
um so the next talk will be by schwetten
on fpt algorithms for finding near
cliques in c closed graphs
hi everyone
my name is shweta jain i'm a postdoc at
the university of utah
this is joint work with bill ramberra
edinhusage who's
here in the audience today uh timber of
garden and my phd advisor seshadri
commander
so
the inspiration for this work actually
comes from real world graphs
subgraph counting is one of the most
important problems that is looked at
on saturable graphs and we look at sub
graphs like cliques near clicks whereby
near clicks we mean cliques that are
missing a small subgraph
and the reason these are important is
because they have they're used in many
many applications including
community detection
edge prediction spam detection
clustering and many many more
so
many of these problems and these abrupt
counting problems are actually np hard
and yet something interesting has
happened in the last few years
uh
many
extremely simple backtracking algorithms
have proven to work very well in
practice
and there have been a number of works
that have appeared in the last few years
uh each of those progressively trying to
get better and better run time in
practice
and to give you a sense of how well
these perform
they're able to count cliques and new
york leaks in graphs with millions of
vertices and edges in minutes
so um this is a plot from one of our
recent papers um
on the x axis i have four
big real world graphs and the sizes of
these graphs are in the table on the
right
as we can see they easily run into
millions of vertices and edges
and
so the y-axis has time in seconds on log
scale
so ignore the red lines for now
the lightest blue line corresponds to
the time taken by this algorithm to
count all cliques in these graphs
ah and the slightly darker ones they
correspond to the time taken by the
algorithm when it was also trying to
count
the per vertex and per edge click counts
which are
harder problems than getting just the
global counts and as you can see in
three out of four cases the algorithm
actually terminated in minutes
in the case of orcut it took about a
couple of hours
and this was on a commodity machine
and this algorithm is
sequential although it can be paralyzed
but this version was sequential
and so the bottom line is that these
algorithms work very very well in
practice
so clearly
the structure of the graph is helping
the algorithm perform well it is not
worst case
and so from the point of view of beyond
worst case analysis this raises an
important question which is what
structure is leading to this behavior
so in order to address this a graph
class called
c close graph was
recently proposed
um
this was proposed in 2018 by jacob fox
timber of garden city commenter fan bay
and nickel wine
and the idea here was to capture this
notion of triadic closure which is a
property that a lot of real world graphs
show
and essentially
what it what it says is that a friend of
a friend is likely to be a friend so a
lot of these two parts tend to be
tend to be triangles
so the formal definition of this graph
class is
a graph has c closure
if every pair of vertices that have c or
more common neighbors are themselves
connected
which means that if you have these two
vertices u and v
which have c or more neighbors then
there has to be an edge between u and v
and if g is the closed then it is also c
plus 1 close c plus 2 close and so on so
we pick the lowest value of c
so here are just some examples for c
equals 1 it's uh this joint union of
cliques you can have c equals two
sequence three and so on
so in the same paper the author showed
that uh maximal click enumeration
can be done in fvt time and this is a
price surprising result considering that
in general graphs even approximating the
max leak is
uh cannot be done in fpd time
so following this there were a series of
works um counting different kinds of
patterns uh one notable work is that of
corner from 2020 computing tensions
power subgraphs uh
this paper also counted k plexus which
is also one of the near cliques that we
looked at so this was part of this was
concurrent work at that time
and then there have been a number of
works that have tried to
that have showed that a lot of these
np-hard problems are actually
fixed parameter practical
what we do in this work is we show that
enumerating several kinds of near
cliques
can be done in fpt time and we give
algorithms for that
so the near leaks that we look at are d
plus one plexus
so these new clicks that we looked at
in some sense they are dense graphs so
it might be easier to think of them in
terms of the sparse version of these
graphs in the complement graph so d plus
one plex is basically the complement of
a bounded degree graph
and
so we also looked at complement graphs
of boundary degeneracy graphs complement
graphs of boundary tree with graphs
our proofs they come in two different
flavors
so the first one is simple it uses a
very simple backtracking approach
and
the second one uses a the three-step
approach that was used by the original
authors
and both of these have their advantages
so the first one
being closer to reality it or the
algorithms that are used in practice
it gives a better sense of why these
algorithms are working fast and so in
some sense it bridges that gap between
theory and practice
and the second the second
approach it has the advantage that in
certain cases where we don't have don't
yet have backtracking
algorithms ah this approach can still
give us ah fbd bonds and
so in some in some cases in fact this
approach can end up giving us tighter
bonds as well
so ah in the process of proving these
results we also proved that
we also gave a moon mosatype bound for
the number of two plexes
in general graphs and this bound the
state and this is the only other
known result of this kind other than the
moon was a bound for
max number of maximal cliques
and um
we also showed that some kind of
subgraphs
cannot be enumerated in fed time so not
all kinds of such near cliques can be
enumerated in fbt time
uh we also gave a very simple
backtracking based um
algorithm for counting for enumerating
maximal clicks and we will very briefly
look at this algorithm
uh the algorithm from foxital was not
backtracking based and so
this led to newer understanding of why
click counting is fast in practice
okay
so
um i'm going to very quickly describe a
very generic algorithm um and many of
the
click counting algorithms that are used
in practice are sort of specialized
versions of this algorithm
so what does this algorithm do
given a graph uh it orders the vertices
of the graph
and orients the edges from lower to
higher vertices and in this way it
converts it into a dag
and now one could show that
if you want to get all clicks in the
original graph essentially that boils
down to getting the cliques in the out
neighborhoods of each of these vertices
so what does the algorithm do it looks
at these out neighborhoods and we are
now interested in
finding the clicks in these out
neighborhoods so it's the same problem
we started with
um so what does the algorithm do it
same problem we started with just on a
smaller instance so the algorithm
recurses
and so for every vertex and these out
neighborhoods we spawn a branch
calculate the new out neighborhoods so
in this case one and five is in the
common out neighborhood of uh
six and eight is in the common out
neighborhood of both one and five
and so on and so basically at every
recursive call we have some sub graph
that we are interested in getting the
clicks in
and this process continues until there
are no more sub graphs left
and one can show that um basically every
path here from a root to any node in
this forest this
gives us a unique click from the
original graph
um all the blue nodes at level 1
correspond to clicks of size 1 and
at level 2 correspond to clicks of size
2 and so on
and
basically the size of this enumeration
forest is equal to the number of clicks
in the graph
so what happens in the case of
c closed graphs
so think of um consider a missing edge
uv in the original graph
um we're going to define
two kinds of nodes so
if the sub graph that we are looking at
if that sub graph is a clique then we
know that we don't need to
explore that branch further we can just
take that click combine it with the
vertices on the path and get a bigger
tree and then we can check for
maximality
um
but so there are leaves are
cliques and then the internal
nodes of this tree they have to have
some missing edge so consider a missing
edge from the original graph say uv
the question is how many
nodes or how many subgraphs can
this missing edge appear in
so remember that everything that is on
the path to that node has to be a
neighbor of uv and since we are in the
sql setup where uv is constrained to
have no more than c com neighbors
that means that
the number of such unique paths that can
lead us to a node that contains the edge
missing edge uv
can be at most
2 to the c
and so since we have at most n square
missing edges that means that the number
of internal nodes here would be at most
n square times 2 to the c
and
since every internal edge an internal
node can have at most
in children that gives us that the size
of the tree can be at most n cubed times
2 to the c and
if you're a little more careful you can
show that it is actually n square times
2 to the c
okay so that was just to give a taste of
what kind of things we can do in the c
close setup
we show results for d plus 1 plexus
these are complement graphs of bounded
degree graphs um
and so for example a one plex is
basically a clique
um
and what so
the triple bound is two to the n times n
square and
only very recently
someone showed that
this can actually be done in
gamma d to the n times n square where
gamma d depends on d
and the value of committee is less than
two
and so this was shown very recently um
and
what we show is that in this c close
setup you can actually find all maximal
d plus one plexes in time n to the 2 d
times
2 to the c
and
in the process of showing this we also
showed that
the moon was a type theorem which says
that the number of maximal twoplexes
in general graphs can be at most 10 to
the power n over 5 and this is tight
and
we also show that
enumerating
code degenerate graph so a graph is d
degenerate if every induced sub graph
has at least one vertex with degree at
most t
and so graph is code degenerate if its
complement is
degenerate
uh degenerate and
what we show is that maximal code
degenerate graphs can also be counted
enumerated in time n to the two d plus
four times four c
uh similarly we show result for
bounded cotri width
and we showed that they can be uh listed
in time
into the t plus four times four c uh
four to c
um
where the
uh quarter width is at most t
okay so to conclude we showed that a
number of near tweaks can be enumerated
in ft time in this c close setup
and we also give a type bound for the
number of duplexes in general graphs
but the most important message from this
work which is what one of our
reviewers pointed out is that there are
natural backtracking based algorithms
and factors for finding large clicks and
practical graphs
and the newly proposed c closed analysis
framework for the first time explains
why
and thus further study of this c-close
framework is one of the most promising
directions for theoreticians to
contribute to this practically important
algorithmic setting
thank you
okay in the interest of time we need to
move straight on to the next speaker so
uh yes mean you can set up
sure can you stop sharing please thank
you
all right so uh yeah this talk is on
vertex fault tolerant emulators and it's
a joint work with
uh greg putwin and mike dennitz
um
okay so let me start by
uh defining spanners um given a graph g
you say that the sub graph
h is a t spanner of g
if for all nodes uv
the distance between u and b and h is at
most c times the distance between u and
v and g
so for example here you see this graph g
which is a dense graph and then
you see a sparse sub graph that
preserves the distances of the factor
three for all purse
um
okay so
what is an emulator
an emulator is similar to a spanner but
it does not have to be a sub graph
so still for all nodes we want to
preserve the distances of the factor t
um
and
the difference here is that we're
allowed to add edges so for example you
see a graph g here
and
you see a tree emulator and you see that
we could add some new edges here
okay so the main question in the context
of spanners and emulators is that we are
given a parameter
t which is the stretch or the
approximation factor
and our goal is to see
how many edges
we need to get a t spanner
t emulator
for graphite endnotes
and
we know the answer to this question
uh we know that for any k at least two
any graph has a 2k minus one spanner
with uh roughly n to the one plus one or
k edges and we also know that
assuming a conductor is true this is
optimal
also as
nicole pointed out in the intro
we know that spanners and emulators are
in a sense equivalent
in in a sense that um
even though emulators have this
additional flexibility where we can add
edges this does not seem to give us a
better uh stretch and size trade-off
but
the interesting thing that we show in
this talk is that when we think about
fault tolerance settings this
equivalence no longer holds so we can
indeed get fault tolerant emulators that
can be um sparser than spanners with the
same stretch
um and
before i get into that let me tell you
what i mean by fault tolerance
so spanners and emulators are generally
used for distributed computing and
networks
and um
their application is usually in routing
and communication we want a sparse
subgraph that
uh we can use
for routing
um but of course in networks
nodes can fail so for example here let's
say we have this
red spanner
with these red edges and then one node
fails so this spanner is no longer
useful for us so
in a lot of practical settings it makes
sense to think about
[Music]
spanners and emulators
that still
hold the stretch guarantee after a
certain number of faults
in particular
we say that
a graph or a subgraph is f vertex fault
tolerant
if
it's um
property that
it is still a team emulator or a t
spanner
uh even after a set of size f of nodes
uh fail
so um
[Music]
again in non-faulty settings we know how
to get optimal size and stretch
trade-offs as i mentioned
and here our goal is to see
with respect to this parameter f which
is the possible number of faults what is
the size guarantee that we can get
um
and
note that this definition is
easy to understand uh when we talk about
spanners spanners are just sub graphs
but when we think about um vertex fall
tolerant emulators we have to answer
another question and that is
uh how are we gonna set weights for uh
edges that were not in the original
graph
um and um
basically what we need to hold for
this fault tolerance
emulator
to be correct is that for all nodes u
and v
uh we need to ensure that the distance
in
h minus f
is at most
t times uh the distance in g minus f
between the endpoints and it's also at
least
the distance between u and b and g minus
f
so um
what are our options
the first option that comes to mind is
what we would do when we construct
emulators classically so we set the
edge weights for any node that is
that we add to be the distance between
the endpoints
the problem with this definition is that
as soon as there is any fault set that
increases the distance between you and v
uh this is going to cause a problem for
correctness we're basically going to get
an underestimate if we set the weights
this way
um
so the alternative
uh is to
do the following so let's say uh
uv is an emulator edge that was not in g
and we defined the edge weight to be
the shortest path distance after false
so um weight of this edge is d of
d sub g minus f of uv
and in a sense we are saying that we are
allowing ourselves to update the weights
after faults
um and if you think about it this is
really the only natural option that
allows us to even construct fall
tolerant emulators
um but other than this
theoretical motivation i want to um
argue that this also makes sense in
practical applications
so
one
um
practical
thing that is very close to emulators is
an overlay network an overlay network is
basically a set of logical links
uh
where routing in a network uh takes
place
um along the shortest path on this
logical links
and
basically overlay overlay networks are
just emulators so let me show you an
example so for example let's say we have
this
uh logical
link between eng and what happens is
that um routing protocols basically
forward the packet along the shortest
path between the two endpoints of this
edge
so
in a sense
application specific routing protocols
already
do something that is uh very similar to
this automatic weight updating they
basically send the packets along the
shortest path after faults
so it makes sense to do things
this way even in practice
and the quality of the routing would
depend on the quality of our emulator
like or the stretch of the emulator
okay so um
let me get into our results
uh as i promised um we showed that
uh we can construct emulators
uh that outperform um spanners with the
same stretch
uh for a given false set f
sorry falsehood size f so in particular
we showed that we can
get emulators that are sparser by at
least a factor of roughly square root f
but in case of
odd k
we can even go further and
show a lower bound that basically says
that our bounds are optimal with respect
to this
number of faults f
so
um
there are two immediate open questions
the first one is what is the deal with
this uh
difference between even an odd k
um
and
the second question is our bounds have
some exponential dependence on k
and it would be good to eliminate this
dependence even though our main goal was
optimizing based on f
finally we also have some results um on
additive emulators
and here we even get a much stronger
improvement uh when we think about fault
tolerant emulators and in particular we
get an exponential improvement um in
particular there's a lower bound that
says if we want to construct
plus c additive spanners for any
constant c and um falsehoods of size at
least log n
um we basically need n square edges so
we just can't sparsify
but we show that uh we can
get optimal simple algorithms for f
vertex fall torrent emulator for plus
two and plus four emulators
um and these are the bounds
um so with that let me conclude um
so
if you open questions as i mentioned we
would like to close the gap for even k
and
remove the dependence on k in our bounds
also
we want to see what happens if
we have edge failures instead of vertex
failures and it's also
good to see if we can get any algorithms
for other related objects such as
distance circles
with that we finished thank you and
please
watch the full video for more details
okay let's have the last speaker set up
okay so we now have a
our last talk is by um
luka ganasali and
the title is correlation detection and
trees for planted graph alignment
okay hi everyone um
so
all right hi everyone my name is luca
and i'll be talking about correlation
detection in trees for planted grape
alignment
so
since i have only 10 minutes i will only
give a glimpse of the work with it so
please do not hesitate to watch the full
video or to come to me
for further details i'll be very happy
to discuss
so this is a joint work with lauren
soulier and mark lelouch
so first of all what is graph alignment
so well the graph alignment problem is a
very
simple question
which is what is the best way to match
the nodes of two graphs right imagine
that you are given two graphs g and h
and you simply looking for a
natural way to match the the notes of
the first one with the notes of the
second one so this is a bit unclear so
we have to formalize it mathematically
so if we have the same number of nodes
in the graph
we want to find a bijection that
minimizes the following quantity here
so you can easily recognize that
minimizing this quantity is um
is like um
looking for the isomorphism right uh
between our graphs in the case where g
and h are isomorphic well this is just
the uh isomorphism problem so here graph
alignment can be viewed as a noisy
version if you like of the the graph
isomorphism problem
so minimizing this quantity is actually
uh can actually be rephrased as a as a
max an optimization problem
over the set of permutations
which is as you probably know an
instance of the quadratic assignment
problem
which is known to be uh np hard in the
worst case
so what people
do usually do with these problems is
that they study
not necessarily the worst case version
but the mean case version so this is
what we are going to uh to do now
um
so the the correct um
problem now we are looking at is the
planted graph alignment so what is
planted graph alignment the idea is to
study the problem in a mean case setting
where the graphs are now random so they
are not drawn under a random model
and we actually plant a solution in our
data so we know more or less what is the
underlying vertex correspondence pi star
and we will try to recover it
of course just uh upon the observation
of the graph right we we of course we
hide this uh this solution but this is a
way to to judge the performance of our
algorithms right we we know what is the
the underlying ground truth if you like
so the model is very simple um it is the
the the
standard edge training model for graphs
so we simply need here to
introduce some correlation between the
the graphs so we
we draw two graphs say a blue one a red
one and uh edge per edge independently
we
we sample the colors of of the edge so
the edge can be two colored meaning that
it will appear in both graphs with
probability lambda s over n
with probability lambda 1 minus s over n
it is monochromatic so
uh red or blue only
and with the remaining probability there
is simply non uh a non-edge right
and as i said we also need to plant a
solution so we simply relabel uh say
that the second graph uniformly at
random and this will be pi star will be
the the ground truth in our model
right so lambda here
and s are two parameters lambda is the
mean degree of both graphs that have
same marginal distribution
and s is this correlation parameter you
can see that if
s is one for instance the graph will be
isomorphic
but in general s is between zero and one
so the goal now is to estimate we are we
are in a inference bayesian inference
problem we want to estimate the latent
vertex correspondence by star
and the regime we are looking at is what
we call the sparse regime since uh in
terms of signal uh the numbers the
number of edges is of order n so we have
an average degree which is constant and
the correlation is also a constant not
scaling with uh
n a first remark in this setting is that
we cannot hope for uh exact recovery we
cannot hope uh to uh recover every
single vertex
uh in the the correspondence
this is just because in this regime
there are too many isolated nodes in the
graph so if i give you some isolated
nodes of course there is no way to match
them better than just
random guess
so
we are aiming at
an estimator who
overlaps spy star
over a
non-vanishing fraction of the nodes
so the
um
the contribution in this paper is to um
to design a local algorithm which
actually simply looks at neighborhoods
in the graphs
and we'll see that this will bring us to
another problem uh the the tree
detection uh
the tree correlation detection problem
so why is that so well we are given two
nodes in g and h and the question we are
asking is okay is node i not to node u
under the the underlying ground truth pi
star
well a simple answer uh just exploiting
the the local neighborhoods is to so to
look at these neighborhoods we start in
this regime um rooted trees
and uh given a certain depth we are left
with two trees and what we want to be
able to tell is whether these trees are
correlated or not
so this is a hypothesis
hypothesis testing
problem and to be more precise what are
the
the hypothesis so here if we have if
we're in the situation where i and you
are matched
the two neighborhoods will look like
uh
in this regime galton watson trees up to
death d
but they will have a common
intersection right they will be
correlated in terms of
edge presence
otherwise as a first approximation if we
take two nodes
far apart
well the two neighborhoods uh will be
simply independent uh trees right so
this is the typical hypothesis testing
we have the same marginals but under the
the null model they are just independent
under the
model one they are uh correlated
so the the goal is to test p1 versus p0
to do so we
simply compute the likelihood ratio so
the ratio of probabilities
and looking at this quantity actually
can bring interesting ideas
uh because this quantity enjoys a quite
simple recursive computation in terms of
depth right so looking at this
likelihood ratio at depth d
is simply
a function of
likelihood ratios of subtrees at depth d
minus one right so this this brings a
polynomial time algorithm when d scales
at most like log n
and n is the number of vertices in the
graph
so
this will simply be our algorithm acting
like
scores if you like
who will tell you whether you and i are
matched or not
so just a summary of the results in the
paper please uh have a have a look at
the whole
uh video to to learn a bit more so we
are looking for one-sided tests i told
you that we were going to do partial
recovery
um the goal is a bit more in fact we are
asking um to have to output um
to output only uh pairs for which we're
quite certain right so we don't want any
mismatch
this is quite logical in terms of
application because if i tell you i have
a permutation but only half of the nodes
are correctly matched you will tell me
okay where are they
so so here we just want to output maybe
half of the nodes but half pairs will be
correct ones
so the results in the paper so we we
give theoretical sufficient uh necessary
conditions uh for that to be a one-sided
test in a tree problem
so this can also be uh
translated into some conditions
on the parameters lambda and s
the algorithm on trees that i described
simply looking at this likelihood ratio
easily extend to uh the the graph
setting
uh where we end up with a polynomial
time message passing algorithm
for this graph alignment task
and these conditions for the tree
problem um of course give also
conditions on the parameters for the
feasibility the polytime feasibility if
we like uh of the partial graph
alignment problem which improves the
the phase diagram so the phase diagram
now is as follows
we already knew about these
uh red and blue faces so we know that
this um
red face here is the impossible phase we
don't
have don't have signal signal is not
powerful enough and then uh over lambda
s equals four we know that theoretically
there is an exponential time algorithm
that succeeds but what this
contributions um
tend to do is to to to characterize so
this is only what is proven for now of
course we conjecture that these faces
are
uh much wider but we have this easy
phase so easy phase here means uh
polytime feasible with our local
algorithm for graph alignment and
we also exhibit a phase where
the parameters will enable
information theoretic feasibility
but our algorithm however this local
point of view fails
um
and
this may be a clue and uh first clue
about the existence of a hard face for
this problem so this is a
a first uh first
glimpse of what may be uh the the white
heart phase for this uh graph alignment
problem
all right so um i'm done with this uh
presentation thank you very much and
please uh don't hesitate to come to me
for further info
thank you so much to all of the speakers
and your wonderful talks this session
um so even though we're over time
i want to open it up to anyone who's
still here if you have any questions for
any of the speakers
actually i have a question to these uh
vertex fault tolerant emulators
especially the last part um
about sidestepping this lower bound is
also something we observed and it's
interestingly from the same 2017 source
but
we relax the objective
in the sense that you have to preserve
certain distances and we now only
preserve those that get perturbed by
this parameter k
and this way we sidestep one of these
bonds
and um can you give some intuition on
how
what you do to
to improve on the lower bounds
um so um you said you've sidestepped
over a lower bound for
two different objects
or
yeah for this um
fault tolerant
from a single source
where you want to
compute the spanner when you
preserve all fault tolerant distances
from a fixed source
to any target and there's this uh n
squared minus
one divided by f of plus one lower bound
so essentially quadratic which is pretty
similar to what you showed
um
but if you now only preserve distances
that um get an additive increase by at
most k from any f failures
um
so you no longer preserve all distances
this is essentially the idea you relax
the objective and then you can sidestep
the slower bond my question would be
what were you doing
in a nutshell
to get around right so uh the thing
about these emulators the way we've
defined them is that it basically allows
us this
uh weight updating it's kind of giving
us some more power
and
it's kind of i mean i i have explained
the algorithm in the full talk but it
um
in a sense it lets us
connect some pads with this
edges that we can add with emulators
that would otherwise
not be possible with spanners
so in spanish in case of fault iron
spanners we just have to maintain a
subgraph
but here um
like
when we add the spanner edges we along
with those spanner edges we
end up adding um some additional
emulator edges we weren't allowed to do
this with spanners and this basically
lets us add fewer edges in total
and
why does it go
below the spanner bound it's just how
the analysis work it like
there's a averaging argument on how
things work and how we can count these
pads and these edges and basically we
get something that is sparser but
yeah i don't i don't know a very
short answer it was already very
insightful thanks a lot that uh
definitely answered my question okay
yeah let me know if you have uh
questions later
okay uh thank you to all the speakers
again and bye everyone and have a good
rest of itcs
thanks bye
thanks nicole bye